ghostface are you there and will you
introduce our next guest please welcome
melissa barrera
thank you
thank you so much i i mean i actually
that clip that scene that we shot i
was dying because that was the first
scene that i was doing with nevin
courtney and i'm just such huge fans of
both of them that i was
literally asking matt our director to
sneak pictures of us on the side because
i couldn't believe that i was standing
in front of them both and i was just
trying to be professional and remember
my lines it was insane
um okay i have to ask you this question
because i fell in love with this story
where did you meet your husband
oh my gosh um in a reality show and
every time that i say that every time
that i say that people assume that it
was a dating show but it wasn't it was
actually a singing competition show
kind of like american idol in mexico and
we both started out as singers so that's
where we met he's a beautiful
mariachi
mexican music singer
and and that's how we met 10 years ago i
love this i'm such a romantic
i am
and i did romantic comedies for
20 years like i love it oh my god can we
talk about can we talk about i mean i
want to know what your favorite romantic
comedy that you ever did but my favorite
romantic comedy that you did was 50
first dates i am obsessed and i was
you and adam obsessed were incredible in
that incredible oh thank you melissa
that means so much to me i'm
really appreciative but i'm also
outside of films i'm a massive beauty
junkie and you
are the global ambassador for clinique
and i love clint so much it's literally
since i was a kid it's one of my
favorite beauty brands it's still reigns
supreme
how is teaming up with them how is that
going i'm so excited as a beauty junkie
fan tell me everything oh my god i am so
i feel so lucky to be
an ambassador for a brand that's all
about
embracing everyone's natural beauty
and uh and i'm the first latina
ambassador for a brand that's so big in
latin america i also grew up
with my entire family using clinique
products so it's such a full circle
moment and i just feel so proud to
partner with them and and keep working
on making that
confident
radiant look that comes from inside that
comes from the way that we feel every
day achievable because everyone deserves
to feel that way i totally agree that
said what's your favorite clinique
product right now
oh my god there's so many good ones but
if i had to pick one i would say the
clinique moisture surge 100 hours
because it's this beautiful dewy gel
very bouncy texture you just put it on
you can put it under your makeup you can
put it over your makeup um if i am not
going to use makeup at all i just use it
to give me like this beautiful dewy
radiant look and uh it's for all skin
types and for everyone and it's just
beautiful it moistures and it hydrates
your skin well everyone in the studio
audience is actually going to go home
with that today because we are teaming
up with clinique
so you are going to get home with a
selection of clinique products
thank you so much
um
okay melissa before we go can i ask you
some rapid fire questions because i'll
scream things aside i want to know about
you
okay okay okay i'm nervous all right so
what is the song in heavy rotation what
are you listening to right now um i
think i mean driver's license by olivia
rodrigo i still am listening to that
okay the last lie you told
i don't know i guess i i i told uh i
told someone that i was doing press when
i really wasn't because i didn't want to
go out and get exposed to covid
favorite favorite food craving right now
you're binging what
any indian food or thai food all the
time okay you're stranded on an island
what are you gonna have with you one
thing a deck of cards i guess
good answer
i would entertain myself with a deck of
cards i feel like i could play solitaire
for
a long time and the next question i feel
like i already know the answer do you
believe in love of first sight yes or no
i mean i have to i did it happened for
me so yeah exactly
and i'm so happy for you all right now
the question i've asked everyone in the
cast
what is the scariest thing about you
i am capable of doing a lot for the
people that i love
is that scary
i mean
it can be scary
like if someone hurts someone that i
love i think i i could hurt them back
congratulations on
just
everything that is happening in your
life it is so well earned scream is out
in theaters january 14th
and um
we'll just can't wait to watch
everything you do and thank you so much
for coming on the show today
thank you i love you thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]